hey guys it's me Alex I'm with my wife
and her boyfriend Don Terrace we just
found out uh we're pregnant dantarius is
the father and we're here to do the
gender reveal so
twisted honey
[Applause]
Dave Rubin Back In The Free State of
Florida and I have to tell you although
I did enjoy our three days in DC and
obviously we'll we'll recap a little bit
of that today it was just so good
Landing in Florida like as the plane
when they're like The Descent has begun
I actually become Matthew McConaughey in
interstellar remember that moment in
interstellar when he's watching all of
the videos that he's missed over the
years when he's on that that journey
into space and time and everything's
bending around him and he's seeing his
children grow up and all of these things
happen in life and his father-in-law
passes away and he's crying tears of joy
and his fake that's me Landing in
Florida every single time I'm so happy
to be back here amongst the joyous free
people we did have a great three days in
DC I mean it was jam packed I want to
just go through quickly before we get to
the show today uh the list of people
that we we interviewed and a little bit
sort of behind the scenes of what it
goes into doing a three-day jaunt in DC
that like what we did because we tried
we really tried our best to get people
from across the aisle uh and alas it
didn't quite work out that way although
we did get plenty of Republicans who
have diverging opinions on a series of
things which actually happens in the
Republican party not so much in the
Democrat Party but just real quick the
list of people that I sat down with uh
Dan Crenshaw from Texas Ron Johnson
senator from Wisconsin obviously Matt
Gates congressman from Florida Lauren
bobert congresswoman from Colorado uh
McCarthy Kevin McCarthy who obviously
now congressman from California but he's
the Speaker of the House Senator J.D
Vance Congressman Jim Jordan Congressman
Byron Donalds congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor green and we got to clean up a
lot of sort of the rumors and stuff
around her my own congresswoman it was
the first time I ever met her and I
absolutely loved this woman it was just
a a serious Joy you probably don't even
know her name she hasn't sort of gone
National yet but I hope this helps
amplify her a little bit Maria Salazar
she was just wonderful we did a live
show yesterday at noon that you may have
seen uh with Senator Ted Cruz and then
we finished up yesterday with chip Roy
from Texas and Thomas Massey from
Kentucky now as I said we did not get
any Democrats I want to be clear we
reached out to over a dozen democrats
for the first two days nobody even
responded now every Republican that we
reached out to at least responded we
were actually supposed to have two other
Republicans that we were going to sit
down with we were going to sit down with
Senator Mark Marcia Blackburn from
Tennessee but then obviously there was
this horrific shooting which we'll be
covering a little bit today so she
didn't come to DC she was back home in
Tennessee and then we were also supposed
to sit down with Senator Rand Paul from
Kentucky uh but in a like Beyond
horrific uh incident one of his staffers
was stabbed fatally wounded not fatally
wounded uh it was it was seriously
wounded though he was said multiple
times uh from what they can tell it was
completely random it had nothing to do
with him Rand Paul himself or the guy's
job sounds like the guy will be okay but
obviously Rand Paul had to uh had to
cancel on that on the Democrat side
uh for the first two days nobody
responded to us then finally Believe It
or Not illahan Omar's people said we'll
get back to you they never got back to
us and uh Rashida talib's people just
gave us a no and you know me I like to
give credit where credit is due I'll
take a no and you've told me something
and by the way they don't owe me
anything we gave them you know a week's
notice or sometimes it may have been two
or three weeks in some cases some of
them were somewhat last minute but the
Congress is in session these guys
they're politicians they don't have that
much to do so you'd think they'd want to
be interviewed by people I'm not noted
as the most Hardball interviewer on the
planet I would have treated them with
respect but I will give Rashida to leave
this is a once in a lifetime moment Dave
Rubin I'm getting Applause here in
studio is giving Rashida to leave credit
because her people actually responded
and said no and Ilan Omar's people at
least responded with a non-response but
nobody else even responded and and
ironically or I guess not ironically I
guess obviously actually would have
better word for it obviously that right
there the idea that a certain set of
people are willing to sit down talk
about their ideas again I challenge
these guys on different things it was
obviously it's I always do it you know
me so I do it in a as friendly a matter
as possible some of these people I do
consider friends and I also don't
pretend to hide my feelings so I asked
almost every single one of those people
what do they think about this Trump
DeSantis divide I have opinions on it
too you've got guys like Matt Gates who
are totally in Trump Camp you've got
guys like chip Roy who who has already
endorsed DeSantis even though DeSantis
hasn't even announced he's running but
we can all do it and sit there and be
respectful and that really was one of
the interesting things about being in DC
I also want to give a shout out uh to
the hundred or so people that showed up
we did a live interview with Kevin
McCarthy in the capital in the Rayburn
room and we had about 100 local
subscribers who joined us it was great
great seeing you guys and then everybody
broke off and did tours of the capital
and as Kevin McCarthy said repeatedly
the people's house is now open there was
a certain energy there there was a
feeling like maybe some sanity can come
back but the problem guys is that uh if
one side wants sanity and something like
Civility and the other side just wants
you know as what I always say is that
endless descent to hell and and the
anger and you're all bigots and racist
and you want to kill kids and the rest
of it uh we got a problem because how do
you how do you connect those two things
that you know it's like connecting two
batteries with the same side and it's
just not going to work right you need
you need two pieces that fit to come
together and that's what we're dealing
with right now so the theme today really
is civility uh versus uncivility and we
have a couple clips that are going to
lay that out for you really really
easily including you may have seen a
viral clip from yesterday uh this guy
Bowman what's Bowman's first name uh
Jamal Bowman who's a congressman from
New York uh about an hour after I left
Thomas Massey so I had Thomas Massey and
ship Roy our studio was about I don't
know maybe half mile from the capitol
about an hour after we finish our
interview Thomas Massey who couldn't be
nicer he's kind of a dorky guy he's like
an electric engineer he wears a debt
Clock an electronic debt clock on his
jacket like the guy couldn't be nicer
more friendly Smiley like the type of
person that you would want in politics
right not an ideologue like you get what
he he says what he believes
this guy Jamal Bowman Democrat from New
York just went off on him in the halls
of the Capitol and it was caught on
video and it's just Showmanship and
rudeness and getting in his face and
actually I think kind of pushing him a
little bit like it really was just awful
uh so we're gonna compare and contrast
the two sides and see what's what before
we do that let me talk to you guys about
balance of nature you guys know that
nothing is more fundamental than the
fact that fruits and vegetables are good
for you someone said that to you when
you were a kid right but eating all the
fruits and vegetables you need can be
time consuming and expensive that's why
I take balance of nature it gives me a
foundation of nutrition and the positive
effects of a wide variety of fruits and
vegetables in just a few seconds see why
hundreds of thousands of people take
balance of nature every day get 35 off
your preferred order when you use
discount code Dave that's right 35 off
your first order just by using discount
code Dave and now back to me I did take
some of them this morning and can't you
see I'm full of fruit and vegetable
right now all right let's talk about
civility or the lack thereof obviously
there was this horrific shooting in
Tennessee we are going to get to some of
the specifics of it and some of the
Fallout but you guys know what happens
when when one of these shootings occurs
depending on the skin color and religion
of the shooter depending on the skin
color and religion of the victims we
either blow it up and make it a huge
story when I say we I mean the
mainstream Media or we completely hide
it if it doesn't fit the narrative and
this one because it apparently was a
trans shooter and Christian victims does
not fit the media narrative so the
mainstream corporate press people are
are going bananas because this one was
too horrific
to ignore but they don't know how to put
this into their sort of very binary
brains where they can't really think of
things think about things holistically
they can only do partisan attacks so
here is
yeah it's the view it's the view
that's good that's good uh here is Joy
Behar on The View going off on Senator
Marsha Blackburn because she is a
senator from Tennessee uh talking about
how she doesn't care about kids now just
remember again we were supposed to sit
down with Marcia Blackburn that day she
did not come to DC because obviously she
stayed home in light of what had
happened in Tennessee here's Joy
nothing
they'll do nothing
nothing they do nothing it's all about
the money you know Marshall Blackburn is
a senator from Tennessee
um she of course sent out her thoughts
and prayers she is 13th on a list of
senators who received the most money
from the NRA
um she received over 1.3 million in
donations while representing a state
with 1
273 gun deaths a year
okay follow the money this is what this
is all about the gun lobby all these
people who are selling guns they make a
lot of money off of children's deaths
apparently in this country they're
worrying about you know other people
books
bologna items
foreign
items pretty sure the injectables in her
face are filled with bologna lady
there's just so much here look let me
try to do this I'm going to try to do
this in like a calm non-partisan way uh
first off that her original notion that
they do nothing meaning Republicans and
conservatives do nothing when these
shootings occur
all right that is based in the I would
say Canard that somehow if you give
people guns or if people are to exercise
their second amendment rights it is your
second Amendment right to be able to
defend yourself your home your property
your family Etc you are it is it is the
Bill of Rights they protect our rights
they didn't give us our rights right God
God gave us our rights we have inherent
human rights
the idea that they do nothing
Republicans do nothing because people
got shot the implication is that most
people if they had access to guns would
just start shooting and murdering people
and that simply is not true right a gun
in and of itself can do good things and
bad things a gun can shoot a guy on his
way to murder somebody that's good a gun
can accidentally go off and kill an
innocent person that's bad it's like
fire fire can heat your home that's good
fire can burn down your home that's bad
so the idea that they will do nothing as
if because what she's really saying is
after these things happen they should do
what we want and what we want is to take
away the gun so here you have a lifelong
New York liberal trying to tell the
people of Tennessee how they should live
it's kind of funny because I don't sense
a lot of people in Tennessee trying to
tell the New York liberal how to live
they're just saying to the New York
liberal stay out of our freaking lives
and that is one of of the differences
that we have right now between the
attitude of I would say the blue State
people and the red State people
um so that was that was one piece of
that then of course it's follow the
money that that Marcia Blackburn only
has these beliefs her belief in the
Second Amendment because of the NRA you
know it's funny as far as I know Phoenix
you can double check me on this on the
fly as far as I know no uh Mass shooter
in American history has ever been a
member of the NRA there have actually
been members of the NRA like in that
Texas church shooting about a year ago
who stop and kill the shooter because
they have guns and they are properly
trained and everything else but this
idea that that everyone who doesn't
believe what you believe is somehow
bought off they are controlled by the
NRA it's just it's just absolutely
disgusting and so yeah so she's
connecting it's they do nothing money
and the NRA those are the big pieces
there what she really wants is hey let
us control you uh by the way Illinois
you know she referenced the amount of
shootings in uh in Tennessee Illinois
had is that 1741 deaths or or is that
deaths by shooting deaths by shooting
Illinois and Illinois gun deaths
Illinois has basically uh the strictest
gun laws in the entire country anyway it
continued on The View because the other
part
when I mentioned how sometimes if the
color of the shooter or the ideology of
the shooter fits and the victims if that
fits the narrative and we know what that
narrative is they love it if it's a
white Christian shooting minorities then
this is the greatest thing ever for the
media if it doesn't work out that way
they don't know exactly what to do with
it in this case it was a trans shooter
going into a Christian school now you
would believe
by by any notion if someone walks into a
temple and shoots a bunch of Jewish
people it is obviously somehow connected
to their religion much like this is
obviously connected to their religion of
Christianity but that does not compute
for these people it does not work in
their very deranged worldview so here is
Whoopi having no knowledge no knowledge
of what she is saying saying that no
this was not about these people being
Christians
and until that conversation becomes a
real conversation that everybody's
willing to get on board with children
are going to keep getting shot people in
churches are going to keep getting shot
I heard one guy said well you know this
is this is against the Christians no
it's not against a Christian because you
would have mentioned it when they went
into the black church and you would have
said this is an issue we should be
thinking about what you didn't so let's
not do that and let us not make it let's
not make it about transgender people
let's not make it about anything but
what it is we have a problem with this
gun and its accessibility in this
country
she's just wrong
she's just fundamentally wrong you know
I have guns in this house
I would never take those guns and go
into a church or a mosque or a school
and shoot someone I have those guns so I
can protect my family and my property I
know that several of the other people in
this room have guns and that's the same
reason they have it it's about mental
illness and ideology that's what this is
about but she dismisses all of that and
and it's really bizarre that she she
really doesn't want you to think it has
anything to do with the victims being
Christian but it obviously does this
person was not happy with the way they
perceive Christian people to treat trans
people okay you know there's this
Manifesto supposedly I think it's a 27
page Manifesto that they're trying to
figure out whether they should release
right now and I'm actually 50 50 on
whether they should release it I was
discussing it off camera with Thomas
Massey because on one hand i'm for
transparency obviously right and so on
one hand you'd want to get it out so
you'd have a little more insight into
actually Why did the this person do this
the problem though is that once you
release it and then it goes viral and
people are clipping it and reading it
and it's read everywhere in the people
everyone knows this person's name and
all that you're actually incentivizing
the copycatters to go boy if I do
something
unimaginably evil like evil that is that
is so anti-human
that you really can't think about it
killing children uh the media will read
my scribe they will read my Rants and I
will become famous after life so there
is a push and a pull on that that I
think you can make good arguments on on
both sides but she is completely
dismissive of the fact that the victims
were Christians she only wants to make
this about guns and she somehow connects
that to when when there has been
shootings in black churches except
Whoopi when when there have been
shootings in black churches churches
it's because they're going after black
people and they're going after
Christians who happen to be black in
those churches you're the one
disconnecting reality from all of this
this is about mental illness and it's
probably and I think we will find more
about this and we usually do it's about
mental illness and it's about
prescription medication and and what
this stuff is doing to war minds and
then you take these warped minds and you
throw them in a world
that has endless scroll where boys or
girls and girls are boys and not racists
or racist and all of the untruths that
we know about you do that over and over
and over again to a 14 year old brain
and by the time that brain is 18 years
old it might do something horrific it
might absolutely do something horrific
on top of the fact that I don't want to
speculate too far but as several people
have brought up if this person was in
fact trans it's a little unclear to me
whether this person had transitioned all
the way or whatever it was but we know
that this was a biological girl who was
going by he him pronouns and there was
some level of the trans stuff there if
it turns out that she was on
testosterone which is what they put
young girls on when they are
transitioning them right their bodies do
not create it so then they are trying to
make them male you put them on
testosterone
do you think testosterone has a little
something to do with aggression you
think that might be a piece of this so
this one this one I'm telling you guys
this one's going to be pushed under the
rug swept under the rug so quickly
because every piece of it from the the
shooter the evil shooter at the Warped
mine that did this to the victims none
of it computes the way that these things
are supposed to compute for the system
and if the system is really good at one
thing it's good at hiding the things
that don't fit the grand narrative we
got a whole bunch more let me talk to
you about fast growing trees real quick
uh you know you could breed some life
into your own backyard with
fastgrowingtrees.com this spring I just
got a bunch of citrus trees from them uh
from shade to fresh fruit to privacy and
nature beauty let fastgrowingtrees.com
help you plant your dream garden with
their expert advice and fast reliable
shipping fastgoingtrees.com plant
experts curate thousands of easy to grow
plant shrub and tree varieties for your
unique climate Meyer lemons to
Evergreens and everything in between no
more waiting in Long lines and hauling
heavy plants around with
fastgrowingtrees.com you order online
and your plants and your plants arrive
at your door in just a few days I love
fast growing trees and we just put in we
put in Citrus lime lemon and orange in
our backyard you get a 30 day alive and
Thrive guarantee so that you know
everything will look great fresh out of
the box join Over 1.5 million happy fast
growing trees customers go to
fastgrowingtrees.com Reuben now to get
15 off your entire order and obviously
with the season changing right now
Springs rolling in pollen's out there
you might want to plant some stuff right
now 15 off at fastgrowingtrees.com
Reuben right now okay
so look we can talk about the shooting
all day I wanna I actually want to
basically leave that there and we'll see
what more info comes out um but yes it
is one of those things where they're
going to go after one side's going to go
after the guns uh you know one side is
probably going to try to go over over
the top on going after trans people I I
don't blame anyone but the shooter and
perhaps the the psychiatrist and and the
people you know whoever was infecting
this young person's mind with the bad
ideas that would lead them to this that
that's where you lay blame you don't
blame blame on on a collective of
individuals that's what we're always
trying to fight around here but what
this all leads us to is something about
civility uh because it is seemingly
going out the window I I try to do my
best with it but you guys know that I
joke and I drop some f-bombs and talk
about the Socialists and all the crazies
and sometimes you have to and as many of
you said to me when we went out for
drinks uh on Tuesday night after the
McCarthy interview you guys dig that
because you're feeling it too it's it's
a release some of that is a silly
release right I'm certainly I don't
think anyone in their right mind would
say I'm trying to Gin up hate here I
know there are people who do say that
but I don't think they're in their right
mind but civility especially in politics
is is being completely wiped away
and as I mentioned I interviewed Thomas
Massey yesterday alongside ship Roy
Thomas Massey congressman from Kentucky
he is he is just a light fun decent guy
he's the type of guy you're like I can't
believe you're a congressman because
you're just kind of like a goofy fun guy
he's he's also brilliant and he has his
house running completely off the grid
using an old broken Tesla battery I mean
the guy's done some amazing stuff in any
event he is a proponent of the Second
Amendment he does believe in gun rights
he owns several guns uh he has been a
strong supporter of the Second Amendment
Etc he was walking in the halls of the
Capitol this is we were right In This
Very Room the video we're about to show
you we were in this room my whole team
was in the room a few hours earlier
and here is Thomas Massey basically
getting accosted by New York Democrat
Jamal Bowman over the shooting and just
watch the difference in tone in content
and behavior it's rather extraordinary
a freaking cowards they're gutless
they're not here I'm talking about I'm
talking about gun violence you know
there's never been absolutely
[Music]
not Lobby
states that have open County laws have
more debt in every school
systems
[Music]
what cause that children are dying
nine-year-old children because their
solution is not harming teachers
have you ever worked in a school
okay I'll bring it down a notch all
right
I've got a bill to repeal I didn't work
in the schools
every I worked in a school for 20 years
so I worked with school 20 years and
every single I was a teacher I was a
spirit counselor I was a middle school
principal I was in cafeteria's
protecting kids every day of my career
[Music]
it's time we've got friends here to
protect us
should have somebody to protect them
every school that's allowed it has never
had a shooting not even an accidental
discharge at any of the schools
there's so much there first off I mean
look the obvious stuff like just the
general behavior of these people Jamal
Bowman is just grandstanding screaming
getting in Massey's face he touches him
a couple times uh Massey is clearly
trying to explain something to him right
he's clearly trying to explain hey you
know and we all went through this
firsthand uh there are metal detectors
when you walk into the capitol there are
armed security guards everywhere
literally every hallway every door uh
Outside Inside everywhere now I'm
actually not taking the position that
that's what we want at every school
because I do think over time if you sort
of just militarize everything uh the the
changes in behavior for people will not
be in that good I think there's a
there's a psychological and mental
component to this that we really have to
deal with but the the general idea of of
oh we all walk around with security we
have metal detectors we have people out
there but we let these schools not be
guarded by by anything is clearly the
right one so there's a tone issue and
that Bowman is doing exactly what
lefties do with virtually everything it
doesn't matter if you know what you're
saying if you just stand in a big room
knowing that there's cameras there and
scream a certain amount of people think
oh he has righteous indignation so he
obviously is right but of course he is
not you know there's another interesting
piece of this as I mentioned and
hopefully some of you guys saw it at
noon yesterday we had Ted Cruz in and we
did it wasn't an interview we just ran
through Clips with Ted Cruz about a
bunch of things and we were talking
about the Tennessee shooting Ted Cruz
brought a bill to the floor about a year
ago that would have had an armed guard
at every school in the United States
public school private school Charter
School Etc every single Democrat ruled
against it
okay so now I get it they want to get
rid of guns altogether because they only
want in essence the state to have the
guns because you know what's going to
happen then we'll all behave that really
is what this is all about they want
centralized power and a bunch of uh I
don't know fish people basically with no
backbones who are going to behave as
they wish so it's a it's a tone issue
and it's a lack of understanding and
also when he keeps saying have you ever
worked in a school have you ever worked
in school it's utterly irrelevant it is
absolutely utterly irrelevant uh Thomas
Massey he kept his cool the entire time
he tweeted this after
he said he tweeted out the video as you
can see and then he said he wanted to
discuss solutions to school shootings
but when I offered a solution he began
shouting when he asked for data I gave
him data but then he just shouted more
bring facts there's never been a school
shooting in the hundreds of schools that
allow staffs to carry
okay I want to go a little further with
this because
you really need to understand that
what's happening in DC is indicative of
what I started with at the top of the
show we got I believe it was 12
Republicans to sit down with me too that
had to cancel because of their own
issues and no Democrats would talk to me
this is a problem and when a guy like
Jamal Bowman
uh when he starts thinking that Thomas
Massey is the extremist is the is the
gun maniac and all that stuff we got a
real problem so I thought we'd just show
you uh just two little Clips we're going
to post the full interview that we have
with Thomas Massey and Chip Roy but I
want to show you two little Clips Thomas
Massey his main thing is about dead this
guy is into the financials he actually
he made it himself we're going to show
this to you in just a sec a debt Clock a
digital debt clock that he wears as a
lapel pin okay and that's what he cares
about most and you tell me does this guy
act just his tone everything about this
guy does he strike you as the extremist
that you want to be yelling at in the
hallway
Thomas I got to start with you because
everyone's going to be wondering about
that thing right there yeah you have the
debt clock on your lapel yeah where's
yours
um you know um some people have a
pacemaker up here a lot of these old
Senators I've got an anxiety maker I'm
trying to make their hearts skip beats
and become concerned uh by looking at
the debt increasing each day it goes I
wrote the software in here I made the
case I've got some 3D printed ones I'm
working on so Chip Roy can have a copy
but it goes to the treasury's website
once a day gets the actual debt to the
penny and then makes its best guess
based on the average debt per second
over the last year about what the debt
is at this very moment I'm gonna guess
that when you're back home in Kentucky
or I should say Kentucky and Texas of
course when you're back home in Kentucky
people probably dig it you come here and
everyone's like could you put that thing
away a little bit of that the Democrats
I had one in an elevator look at it and
say is that a doom day clock and I said
yes ma'am it is well they're always
escalating escalating that situation
funny it is a Doomsday Clock but they
they just don't fully realize it uh so
as I mentioned I had on the Republican
side a whole bunch of people Trump
supporters DeSantis people people that
backed McCarthy for the speakership
people that didn't act as a matter of
fact both of those guys did not back
McCarthy at first chip Roy especially
was one of the most outspoken against
McCarthy but they knew that the day
before I had sat down with McCarthy I
had Gates on who's a big Trump guy and
then I had Crenshaw who the base doesn't
seem to be for I tried to bring in a
plurality of opinions but what the theme
with everybody was they are having a
hard time talking to anybody on the
Democrat side and I actually asked uh
Massey about working with AOC and and
the progressives
so when you guys when you guys see AOC
afterwards talk about how this bill was
basically passed by fascist and it's
like man she she needs some better
education because I don't know what it
means uh or uh Hakeem Jeffries you know
they don't want to teach about the
Holocaust I mean these are the responses
you got out of these guys
I've asked this to every Republican I've
sat down with for last three days are
you talking to these guys in the back
rooms going what the hell are you
talking about you know that's not legit
um so I mean in the rules committee we
debated this and Chip was right to point
out they knew that this bill didn't ban
Books Okay because we had already
discussed that the day before in the
rules committee before the debate came
to the whole house they they knew it
didn't ban books but they went down
there and said it anyways because they
knew a lot of their constituents
wouldn't do the due diligence to find
that so what we were referring to right
there is the bill that got passed a
couple days ago this parental rights and
education bill which is basically a sort
of uh copycat version of what we've been
doing here in Florida it's about
transparency and education there's
nothing about banning books there's
nothing about you can't say gay there's
nothing about hiding information about
the Holocaust but AOC we showed you the
clip a couple days ago literally was
calling this bill passed by fascists you
got the other one Hakeem Jeffrey saying
they don't want to teach about the
Holocaust and the point is that these
guys Massey chip Roy some of the other
ones they get out there every day they
try their best to explain why they're
voting for things things that anyone I
mean especially guys I can tell you as a
new parent you want transparency
especially related to your kids why
would I ever want to send my kid to a
school where I just no I am just simply
not allowed to know what they are
teaching that child like think how
actually insane that is but this lack of
Civility does consistently seem to only
go in One Direction Where are all of the
videos of the Republicans screaming at
the Democrats and lying constantly about
what they say actually they just don't
exist but please send them to me if you
can find them and I'll gladly show them
to you and I'm talking about I'm talking
about people in Congress and the Senate
right now not talking about the average
guy on the street but I want to show you
another video you may remember this this
is from March 1st we showed you this
clip Jamal Bowman again congressman from
New York uh this is on I believe it's
the steps to the Capitol uh going after
Byron Donald's Byron Donalds is
Congressman from here in Southwest
Florida he's a good dude a bunch of the
uh Republicans who are supposed to be
racist we're voting for him for
speakership but okay whatever here's
Jamal Bowman going after Byron Donald's
because he supports uh I believe he
calls him white nationalist Ron DeSantis
I called them I said tell me what's
happening they are like uh it's really
not that but people are trying to raise
a fuss I've had the conversations it's
not true I've had the conversation why
can't
those who have been incarcerated who are
released who have done their time why
can't they be re-enfranchised and be
allowed to vote they are in our state
I mean there's so much there he has no
arguments right he's telling a black man
that his friend I mean Byron Donaldson
and Rhonda Santos are friends at uh Ron
desantis's re-election night remember
that 20-point win 1.5 million vote win
that he had back in November you know
who opened for him the only politician
on stage with him that night of the win
yeah it was Byron Donald's okay uh
former felons are allowed to vote in
Florida so he also made that up
um and he's anti-black he's anti-women
he's anti-gay and then this is the same
guy who a month later is screaming at
Thomas Massey about guns as if he wants
people to be killed just because he
believes in the Second Amendment but
this what do we do with this and I
really mean this as an open-ended
question and maybe this will be an
open-ended question for the remainder of
the time that I do this program what do
we do if we consistently are trying to
explain what we believe
why we believe it and and how we want to
accomplish it if the other side is just
there to lie about it and to hold and in
their estimation take us out because we
are the bad guys uh there was another
interesting moment you know one of the
people that I interviewed uh this was
yesterday as well yesterday morning uh
was Marjorie Taylor green congresswoman
from Georgia now if you listen to the
mainstream narrative on her she's a
white nationalist and something about a
Jewish space laser and she doesn't like
black people or something and she's an
insurrectionist I actually found her
quite lovely she was very able to
explain what she believes we we talked
about a little bit of everything uh but
later in the day she was doing a hearing
and they were talking about uh what
happened in Tennessee and she's having a
back and forth uh with uh what's his
name Jason Moskowitz is it Jason
Jeff Moskowitz uh represent I'm sorry
representative Jared Moskowitz about uh
shootings and uh sort of how she evolved
on some of this stuff
any question I'll yield to anyone on
this committee who disagrees that murder
in schools is not murder will you yield
oh I'll yield yes please yeah I was when
I was in 11th grade and Joe Biden made
our schools gun-free school zones one of
the students in my school brought three
guns to school and our entire school
went on lockdown because he was the only
person with a gun there was no good guy
with a gun to protect us kids at school
you want to know why the shooter is dead
in Nashville the trans shooter you want
to know why because the good guy with a
gun killed that woman she identified as
a man she was mentally ill probably
taking hormones and she went in and
murdered children and adults in this
Christian school in Nashville so if you
want to have a good talk about schools
and protecting children we need to talk
about protecting our children the same
way we protect our President we protect
our celebrities we protect time
okay I'll yield thank you Mr chair
you got it it's just the truth these
people exist and are able to scream
about taking away our guns while they
are protected by guns remember that
video we showed you about a month ago as
Gavin Newsom was walking the streets of
California talking about how the GOP is
in a suicide pact with the NRA because
of guns and he's surrounded by like
eight armed security guards because
that's the only way he can go out in the
state of California I know you guys get
it but it's not just the congressman
congresswomen and the Senators who are
disconnected from reality on the left
it's also obviously the president and
the president I would say is
disconnected from reality uh when it
comes to basically everything for
several reasons some of the medical uh
here is his first response this was the
first thing that he said uh after the
shooting
dripping our communities apart ripping a
soul this nation and ripping at the very
soul of the nation
and we we have to do more to protect our
schools so they aren't turned into
prisons
you know the shooter in this situation
reportedly had two assault weapons in
the pistol to ak-47.
so I call on Congress again to pass my
assault weapons ban
no Joe you got it backwards first off
okay the usual slurring that's fine he
doesn't even know what he's saying
again Ted Cruz a year ago tried to get
an armed security guy at the front of
every school so now imagine and there's
no perfect system right there's always
ways around a system I accept that but
now imagine there's an armed security
guard at the door of this school or any
school right the shooter comes up now
you have a standoff you have someone
that is trained and prepared and ready
to defend the students and the teachers
and the faculty Etc but every Democrat
was against that so what the Democrats
are doing while while the bodies are
still warm the Democrats are saying how
can we take guns from you and if you
think for one second that if they can
get whatever they want we want we want
semi-automatics they don't even know
what they're talking about right usually
we always find this out they don't even
know what the definition of the words
mean they don't know the difference
between magazine and clip they don't
know any of this stuff but okay
if you think for one second that if you
give them an inch on guns they will stop
oh we're good guys we got the guns we
wanted let's wrap up shop and if you
first off it's just it's an insane
Theory you would not understand the
ideology of progressivism it is to
progress always on your rights that's
how it works uh but it's not just that
it is that they will always do it and
then they will move on to something else
it's the second amendment that is
protecting the First Amendment right
it's it's just it's just how it is uh
here's another one by Biden uh where
he's conflating a couple different
issues on how Americans feel about guns
in general take a look
really
I don't know if that is true I don't
know what we tried to find some numbers
on that that the majority of Americans
think that having assault weapons is
bizarre we could not find that out but
let's say that is true for a second I I
will try to make your argument for you
Joe if the majority of Americans think
that having assault weapons is bizarre
does that mean then that you should take
assault weapons from people should be we
be ruled by a mob just because most
people think something does that mean
that it is right I think because I have
a wise audience you guys know that that
obviously is not the case imagine and
you could end up in a situation like
this where after generations of
programming young people we could end up
in a situation and I think we may be
heading to that situation where the
majority of people will think that the
First Amendment and Free Speech are bad
they will think there are too many bad
ideas out there two people have too many
uh conflating and conflicting views on
things there's too much quote-unquote
hate speech Etc and once that gets over
that 50 threshold should we take away
free speech should minority viewpoints
not be allowed to be shared in the world
that Joe Biden wants to live and
apparently the answer is yes but then of
course we had to show you a clip of
cringe Jean-Pierre uh where she just
instead of just honestly saying we have
to think about mental health we have to
think maybe we actually are radicalizing
now a whole generation of people because
they're confused about their gender and
their sexuality and all of these things
and what that might lead to instead of
having any honest assessment it's
Republicans want to kill people because
of guns
we must do more and he wants Congress to
act because enough is enough
in his State of the Union the president
called on Congress to do something
to stop the epidemic of gun violence
tearing families apart tearing
communities apart
how many more children
have have to be murdered
before republicans in Congress will step
up and act to pass the assault weapons
ban
to close loopholes in our background in
our in our background check system
or to require the safe storage of guns
we need to do something
most of those laws exist already that's
number one but this idea that it's just
how many more children have to die until
Republicans do what we want how many
more children have to die two
Republicans you're like Constitution
Constitution right no guys no but they
can't they just can't deal with any of
this honestly and do you think that
might be why they'd be afraid to sit
down with a guy like me like am I known
as the the most combative interviewer
I'm actually known as the reverse of
that I used to get a lot of criticism
because I was the reverse of that right
people say Dave's a softball interviewer
okay uh but they're afraid to sit down
with me because what they want to do
what she knows she can do is Biden can
say his nonsense then she can filter it
down and then the mainstream media just
repeats it so they basically never have
to be challenged on any of this and if
you want to see how the mainstream media
also obfuscates the obvious truth about
this stuff look at this headline from
Reuters I mean tell me this is not just
evil
former Christian School student kills
three children three staff in Nashville
shooting so apparently this trans
activist
was at one time a Christian School
student and that is the way they chose
to frame it just incredible then there's
this guy Ben Ryan who he is an NBC guy
we did we confirm that he's an NBC guy
look at this tweet I mean is this just
unbelievable NBC has id'd the Nashville
school shooter as Audrey Hale 28 who
identifies as transgender and had no
previous criminal record Nashville is
home to the Daily wire a hub of
anti-trans activity by Matt Walsh Ben
Shapiro and Michael Knowles
Ben Shapiro Matt Walsh and Michael
Knowles had nothing to do with this the
daily wire being in Nashville had
nothing to do with this we will find out
more about the medication this person
was on the ideology that this person was
following but Ben Shapiro and Michael
Knowles and Matt Walsh never said if you
like us or dislike us or anything else
you should take the law into your own
hands and kill people
uh this is a mental health issue guys it
is a mental health issue guys but look
here's how the USA Today uh covered this
police on Monday afternoon said that the
shooter was a transgender man officials
had initially misidentified the gender
of the shooter do you see how stupid
this is it is so Pro I don't care and no
one in their right mind cares about the
gender of this person right now right
it's going to become political because
they've they've forced this trans stuff
on everybody but you see where the media
is worried about oh my god did we
misgender the the murderer insane
speaking of insane Don Lemon CNN go
the police are identifying the shooter
as a trans woman would actually be a
trans man so there's sort of a
misidentification there but this is all
new I'm just wondering the identity of
being a transgender person and also
being identified as a woman does this
pose any sort of difference or
difficulty for the for police because
it's not typically a woman regardless of
how they're identifying so there are a
couple of things here that are different
and that we're going to have to talk
about and delve into
right so each of these cases is always
going to have a particular difference
right whether it's uh someone is angry
at their father or someone had something
happen at the school and this is a
unique case and we have to be sensitive
about it to the extent that Audrey Hale
identified as a woman we do not see Mass
Shooters who are female especially in
particular school shooting uh murderers
those that is that is uh uh this is
actually I think the first time that I
can remember
okay do you see how they're so focused
on the wrong thing and how they are
making they're basically running cover
for a trans ideology because if this was
a Muslim that went into a church and
shot Christians nobody would be like oh
we better figure this out but everyone
would be and and probably correctly well
first off I would still say there's a
mental health issue because again if you
kill innocent people there's a mental
health issue there but we would be able
to maybe connect this to a religious
ideology and there would be a certain
amount of people by the way people on
the right who then would be unjustly
prejudiced against Muslims if a
Christian shooter went into a Jewish
synagogue or a Jew went into a mosque
right we would be able to somewhat
clearly connect these things but in this
one we better not misgender this person
as a trans man or a trans woman this has
never happened before we should be very
careful as opposed to focusing on the
real victims the way they talk about it
the victim here is the is the shooter
the victim here is the shooter you know
because you know the daily wires in
Nashville and uh you know somebody
misgendered this guy or this gal
insane absolutely insane uh here is a
fake Republican you know these you know
these pet Republicans I'm always talking
about these pet Republicans that go on
MSNBC uh he is a former Congressman
named David Jolly former I'm very happy
to say he's former Congressman because
he was a Floridian Congressman David
jolly and he's a pet Republican which
basically means a Democrat he goes on
MSNBC to just rail against Republicans
and listen to Just The Way They frame
this I mean it just yeah it's about race
go
it's it when you say the word gun
violence one of the things that always
strikes me here and you see it here is
if you say the word crime
Republicans there's no there's nothing
that's too much to go after a crime in
the big cities crime crime is the enemy
throw it if you say gun violence which
is the probably the most deadly subset
of crime
all of a sudden it's like well what are
you gonna do it's just as whatever the
word is that just changes everything
yeah Chris this is going to be hard but
for Republicans crime is something
that's committed by black Americans yes
right gun ownership and gun violence is
something that is part of the culture of
young white men and so Republicans
protect it and that's just
yes oh yeah of course yeah yeah crime
only black people commit crime yeah yeah
yeah yeah
it's so weird because uh it seems to me
that Republicans are the ones that care
about crime in the big city thus uh fund
the police so that there is less crime
in their cities there's a reason that
Denver or is Denver for example uh has
homelessness and drug use everywhere and
Dallas does not one is run by a Democrat
one's run by Republican hint hint he's a
muppet this guy this Chris says he's
just a muppet
but this David Jolly like yes how do you
like do you see how what they did like
instead of dealing with the actual
mental health issues are about this
specific person and this ideology that
is being pushed on children everywhere
instead of dealing with the complexities
related to that it's somehow
Republican's fault oh and also
Republicans are racist when it comes to
all this but not just that here's
another lunatic from MSNBC Republicans
also hate rule of law
we now live in a society where the cops
are afraid of the convicts we're former
presidents
former presidents they make Martyrs out
of convicts who stormed the United
States capital
these these Republicans are the enemy of
the rule of law my God they're talking
about a trans shooter who shot up a
Christian School and he's making this
about January 6th bananas bananas also
cops are afraid of convicts you know
it's funny they're not afraid of them
here in Florida where we have rule of
law and all-time low crime you know
where they are well you know where cops
are afraid and where cops are retiring
early and where they are literally
literally having to lower the physical
fitness standards to become police
officers New York because they defunded
the police Minnesota because they
defunded the police Seattle Portland San
Francisco Los Angeles
not Republican places bananas all right
only one more from MSNBC I promise you
know this guy we've shown a couple Clips
to this guy there's this guy what's his
name what's his first name
a nod his first name to nod his last
name I'm probably going to mispronounce
it is grid haradas
he looks like a villain from Gotham City
I think he broke out of Arkham Asylum
and he is terrorizing well I know he's
terrorizing people because he's on MSNBC
watch this
and then more people see big problems in
their lives that government can't solve
and get demoralized about government
which helps this extremist right
ideology and it is sickening to watch
them try to claim the idea of freedom I
for me the freedom to remain alive or
have my kids remain alive kind of comes
first look at those little kids but also
though they say free they talk about a
freedom they talk about a freedom that
they've made up in their own Twisted
heads because they've been they've been
whipped into a paranoia
do you guys have that searing pain in
your heads right now like a knife
stabbing you in your Abdullah oblongata
medulla
um yeah he's sort of right government
can't solve problems government's not
good at problems the nine scariest words
in the English language I'm from the
government and I'm here to help except e
like every idiot at that table and
everyone on MSNBC and everyone watching
MSNBC their solution is always more
money and more government the government
is evil the government is corrupt
government is is full of elitists
pushing the people down what is the
solution make it bigger make it bigger I
want the freedom to have my children
alive well no so how about we scale
that government which is the number one
thing encroaching on all of our lives
oh wait we have more MSNBC
I'm sorry guys we do have more MSNBC uh
remember John heilman
I feel like I owe everybody an apology
right now I'm apologizing to you guys
I apologize what can I do what can I do
remember John heilman he is the MSNBC
hack who went on Real Time with Bill
Maher about a month ago and Russell
Brand just
filleted this guy just absolutely
filleted this guy
here he is and remember the whole thing
was about whether they lie on MSNBC
intentionally here he is telling an
insanely completely fictitious story
about Republicans and Waco uh I don't
even know what he's talking about here
but go ahead
taking semi-automatic weapons making the
machine guns and it was when the ATF saw
evidence of that and the fact that David
Crush Was raping young girls that they
decided to try to make a move on Waco
and that's what started the whole 51-day
Siege you know that's and those people
are heroes now on the right David koresh
uh and and and the the assault the Waco
the Branch Davidians are now you know
we'll again we'll talk about this more
later but that's how deep it goes and
it's not new the only other thing I'll
say is I agree Eddie like you know some
parts of the culture are obviously
broken
um and it's not all about policy
is a hero on the right uh now I have
three right-wing Maniacs in the room
with me right now how many of you show a
hands guys have a David koresh uh you
know like a bunch of pictures of David
crush's Shrine let's say to David kresh
in your bedrooms anyone in this room
nobody in this room I have never met
anyone on the right that thinks David
koresh is a hero now there might be some
like radical really anti-government out
there something or other that does but
you see how he conflaints that with
every he's a hero on the right he's a
hero on the right this is the same clown
who a month ago got eviscerated by
Russell Brand for saying that nobody on
MSNBC intentionally lies then we showed
you a massive compilation of him lying
on MSNBC and then the guy blocked me on
Twitter but for those of you who forgot
here's Russell just taking him apart
after you have to take responsibility
for our own perspective I've been on
that MSNBC mate it was propagandist not
crackery
good morning Joe it was absurd absurd
the way there good morning Joe yes
no one called Joe there no one could
concentrate they didn't understand the
basic pillars of Journalism no one was
willing to stick up for genuine American
Heroes uh like Edward Snowden no one was
willing to talk about Julian Assange and
what he suffered trying to bring real
journalism to the American people and I
think to sit within the castle of MSNBC
throwing rocks have Fox News is
ludicrous make MSNBC make MSNBC great
again my friend I would love
thing that that morning Joe it's not in
the morning there was no one named Joe
there it's just like
anyway you get it these people they just
lie about everything so now how can we
wrap the show together today in a
positive way I've had to apologize to
you I think I cried a moment ago it's
been a lot today right okay and then
this is serious stuff this wasn't our
funniest show ever but how can we bring
this together in a sane way look uh for
those of us that are are on this what I
would say is this broad right Coalition
right now that's trying to figure out
some stuff and it's going to get
difficult it's going to get difficult
because we're fighting a bunch of people
who will yell at you and shout you down
and call you racist and lie about you
and all that stuff that you know but
it's also going to get increasingly
difficult in the next year especially
because of the presidential politics
portion of this right I've hit Trump a
bit on this show no matter how many
times I say I like the guy I I went out
of my way to support him it cost me a
lot in friends uh and probably
sponsorships and a whole bunch of other
stuff but I don't regret it in any way
whatsoever I haven't been thrilled with
some of his behavior lately but as I
said I sat down with as many Republicans
as possible I sat down with hardcore
ones in the Trump camp like Lauren
bobert and Jim Jordan and Matt Gates and
talk to them about their support for
Trump and they know my feelings about
DeSantis and then I sat down with guys
like chip Roy and Thomas Massey who are
let's say more in the DeSantis camp
how are we going to do this without
destroying each other or will we destroy
each other maybe that's what the machine
really wants right we will actually
destroy each other and then
congratulations we get four more years
of mentally scrambled Joe Biden in the
White House well I talked about just
that with Matt Gates and I thought that
would be a nice way to tie this all
together Gates knowing that I'm more in
the DeSantis camp at the moment and he's
more in the Trump camp and and what do
we do with that
AOC you guys passed the parents rights
and education thing and she's calling it
fascism Hakeem Jeffries is saying they
don't want to teach about the hawk I was
like it's just like lies and craziness
like is there anyone in there that can
sort of stem that or do you think that's
just about broadly I don't know the
answer to that question but I do think
we have to be willing to create
alliances around issue sets where we may
have common ground take for example the
surveillance state that we have I get
real squeamish about the powers that the
Patriot Act and other laws have fused
into the National Security State to
deprive Americans of their Liberties
often in the absence of constitutional
protections and I can find Democrats
like Zoe Lofgren on the Judiciary
Committee or rokana in the Progressive
delegation who will actually work with
me to try to build enduring coalitions
against an establishment that also
includes both Republicans and Democrats
I'm sorry we showed you a different clip
right there there is a clip that we'll
show you tomorrow uh or that you'll see
in the full interview which I think the
full interview's up already right the
full interview is up already it was the
clip that I was referring to we just got
back late last night so we had a little
error there uh where I talked to him
about the DeSantis Trump thing and and
we sort of agreed to disagree and walked
away there like kind of high-fiving and
shaking hands and it's all good
obviously what we were talking about
there was the other theme of the show
today which was that hopefully we can
find some people hopefully Gates can
find some people he mentioned one or two
right there
we'll keep putting our hands out I
promise you I will keep trying to
interview people on the left if they
will sit down I will keep trying to do
it I will keep trying to to not go
scorched earth when it comes to whatever
is going to happen with Trump and or
DeSantis or anyone else like that's
going to be the challenge it will be
very easy to do the other thing it's
very easy to be the Bowman of the
situation it's very easy to just scream
and find enemies everywhere but we're
going to have to do some work uh just
one final thing for today uh Wall Street
Journal put out a poll a couple days ago
that's really really fascinating about
some some disturbing Trends in America
right now talking about values look take
a look at this uh what this is showing
you here uh from 1998 to 2023 so in a
25-year span patriotism has dropped the
belief in the importance of patriotism
has dropped from 70 to 38 the belief in
the importance of religion has dropped
from 62 to 39 the importance of having
children
59 to 30 percent Community involvement
47 to 27 the belief in the importance of
money 31 which is risen to 43 which
might have something to do with the
amount of inflation we have people are
like oh at best I do wish I had some
more money uh but yes guys this is uh
these this is disturbing those those
numbers are all going in the wrong way I
am not sitting here telling that you
that you have to believe in a particular
religion I am not sitting here telling
you you have to have a flag waving
outside of your house we've got a pretty
massive one inside of my house uh or any
of those things but if we don't get back
to a place where we have something
common whether that is a belief in the
United States of America as a
fundamentally decent project uh whether
that is a belief in God or something
Beyond ourself uh whether it is a belief
that being part of your community
matters your local community so that
you're you're you know you walk down the
street and you don't get shot and people
actually take their garbage out and and
clean up when they see trash and all of
those things
it can derail pretty quickly so it is a
battle for the culture and we have to
decide what do we care about what are
our priorities what are our shared
beliefs I'm going to keep doing it I'm
going to keep trying to expand those
things right along with you guys it is
going to get tough it's gonna get tough
like this thing is going this DeSantis
Trump thing is going to get tough and
nasty and everything else but I'll tell
you guys having been in DC for three
days I left the city believe it or not
and when you watch my interview with
Kevin McCarthy I think you'll see it he
says something about how he still every
day he goes into that Capital he'll he
still feels a sense of awe and I do
believe him I feel it when I go in there
it's like great people over generations
and hundreds of years created these
structures meaning these physical
structures but then also these documents
that did so much freaking good we've
still got it so freaking good but but we
have to be able to defend it and we have
to know when forces are coming to take
it out and we have to figure out how we
deal with that in a decent way in a
law-abiding way
we got a lot of work to do but as I
often say I have nothing better to do
than save the world I suspect you don't
either uh in 37 seconds I'll be doing a
post game show if you want to ask me any
questions comment did I screw up
anything today let me know did I play
Too Many clips of MSNBC I think we can
all agree the answer is yes uh my full
interview with Dan Crenshaw is already
up on YouTube and Rumble the full one
with get with Matt Gates is already up
on YouTube and Rumble all the others and
I think it was about 12 in total will be
going up over the next couple days we're
doing them all we're doing them all as
full right they're all what's that
Lauren bobert will be up later today and
we're putting them up all as full right
they're all going up as full interviews
we may do some clips after but we just
wanted you know we did so many that we
didn't want to bludgeon you guys with a
gajillion Clips so that'll all be going
up and uh all right post game show in
just a moment cold close and I'll see
everybody at
reubenreport.locals.com Goodbye
foreign
[Music]